all right I'm delighted to be here today
and uh my talk today is going to be uh
as the title suggests uh challenges and
AI safety from the perspective of an
autonomous driving OEM and OEM is just
it means original equipment manufacturer
emotional uh is partnered and I'll have
a slide on this partner of the Hyundai
Motor Corporation
um so we considers ourselves an oem uh
developing a an autonomous vehicle so
just a quick thing about uh emotional
itself
um we're essentially in a similar
category as uh waymo and Cruz were
developing an autonomous vehicle a
self-driving vehicle
um the technology that comprises our
autonomous vehicle software uh came out
of uh startups from MIT and Carnegie
Carnegie Mellon University and those
form the basis of of our autonomous
software Hyundai Motor Corporation
provides the actual vehicle
um uh that we're going to be using to to
to deliver our Robo taxi service
um
so just a couple of headlines recent
headlines that were announced emotional
announced I believe last year uh a
partnership with Lyft
um emotional will be providing uh
ride-hailing service through Lyft but
with motionals autonomous vehicles we
currently have some test Vehicles
operating uh on the Las Vegas Strip and
uh so in today if you happen to be in
Las Vegas you could actually uh hail a
ride through the Lift app and you can
request an autonomous vehicle and you
would be uh provided that ride with an
emotional autonomous vehicle with a
safety driver behind the wheel but most
of the time the vehicle would actually
be driving itself we also recently
announced a partnership with ubereats
where we're actually going to be used
using the emotional autonomous vehicle
to uh to deliver food meals through the
through the ubereats application so
Essen did a very nice job of introducing
me but just a little bit more on on some
of my technical backgrounds so I started
my career
um around 2000 I I was part of a startup
that ended up failing for from 2000 to
2003 and it was not in the autonomy
space so I don't even put it here
um but I I worked at uh Draper
laboratory for four years uh developing
fiber optic gyroscopes uh rotation
sensors for a U.S uh Navy guided system
and again you can think of that as a as
a as an autonomous system autonomous
vehicle
um where deadly consequences are
actually the intent of the system
whereas with the current product we're
trying to avoid uh any any type of
deadly accidents uh that could occur
from from the autonomy uh for the next
13 years I was at the GE Global Research
in Upstate New York uh that's the
organization that they were the r d
research and development arm for the
General Electric Corporation so I got to
a chance to be exposed to hard technical
challenge problems for the for all of
the GE companies so Aviation
Transportation Health Care
um a power generation and I'm I'm proud
to say that while I was at GE Global
Research that was my introduction to
Stanford and particularly to Professor
Michael kochendurfer and I'm also very
proud to say that in collaboration with
Michael and and Robert Moss when he was
at MIT Lincoln lab I led the group that
was the very first industrial
organization to test flight the acas sxu
versions The a version of acas XU
collision avoidance system for aircraft
that was developed for small uh small
autonomous vehicles uh and from 2020 to
present been I've been emotional for
about a year and a half now I lead the
uh autonomy safety and safety research
organization
um
so about two weeks ago I set out to um
you know I said to myself hey I've got
this talk Stanford coming up I better
start putting some slides together uh
for the presentation and then I ran
across this article uh from you know
three years ago or so that uh Elon Musk
had uh declared that the self-driving
cars were solved so I said you know
hallelujah thank goodness I don't have
to do any work I can stand here and talk
to you about the weather or the San
Francisco Giants for an hour but
unfortunately all due respect to Elon
Musk the self-driving at least at the
level four and level five
um uh levels where it's completely
autonomous no human interaction
whatsoever it is absolutely
categorically not solved uh if it if it
were solved I wouldn't have anything to
talk about but there are hundreds
thousands probably tens of thousands of
of the greatest Minds you know Engineers
uh scientists researchers uh solving
some of the hardest challenges and some
of the hardest challenges do come from
the fact that uh we use a ton of
artificial intelligence to make safety
critical decisions so the outline of my
talk is I'm going to first give a little
bit of sort of a background on the
safety engineering approach and for
folks in my generation and folks that
sort of grew up in the engineering or in
the engineering profession doing sort of
Legacy processes around safety
engineering the introduction of AI is
just has just turned those processes on
their head and the the safety
engineering community today even is just
is grappling with how to adapt uh safety
engineering processes and methodologies
that have served the community extremely
well for decades how do we adapt those
uh to to account for learning enabled
components included in safety in safety
critical systems uh it it's a hard
problem that by itself is a hard problem
uh then I'm going to talk about some key
challenges from say from uh with AI
safety that are very specific to the
autonomous driving Community I'm going
to talk a little bit about some research
topics selected research topics some of
which we're working on with Stanford
currently uh that I believe in my
opinion
are are the most promising research
areas to deal with these very very
difficult uh uh AI problems
um I'm going to talk a little bit about
this notion of how do you um how do you
um how do you quantify risk for an
autonomous vehicle how do you know when
safe is safe enough how do you know when
you've tested all the possible things
that can go wrong that's another open
area of debate it's not solved there are
committees there are research projects
that are trying to deal with those
things right now trying to answer those
questions we don't have a good answer
for that yet and then lastly I'm going
to talk about a research project that's
going on emotional right now being led
by one of my colleagues out of the
Boston office that doesn't deal with
sort of um objective safety it really
has more to do with perceived safety how
the public
interacting with autonomous vehicles on
the on the open roads how they perceive
autonomous vehicles and are things that
we can do in the autonomous vehicle to
um to increase the perception uh that
our vehicle is safe when operating with
with uh with other roads so saved just a
a quick note about safety engineering so
you know there's a long list of
catastrophic events that have that have
occurred you know throughout the
throughout the decades uh uh from from
uh software bugs do the software bugs
okay and they range from the deadly uh
as in the case of the um Toyota
unintended accelerator the acceleration
pedal would just on its own you know hit
the floor and accelerate and the human
in the in the driver's seat had no idea
or no no idea how to you know prevent
that from happening and unfortunately it
led to a number of fatalities
um the Northeast blackout of 2003 you
can see that big area of the Northeast
around New York New Jersey Pennsylvania
that was completely blacked out for a
number of days that was caused by a
software bug okay that's more disruptive
than deadly but when you lose power it
can have deadly consequences as well for
you know people in nursing homes people
in hospitals Etc that depend on a power
power source and then the downright
Bazaar so I don't know this was a few
years ago the Microsoft tabot where they
they generated this AI uh bot that would
listen in on social uh social media
channels Twitter
um you know Twitter in this case Twitter
and it would learn conversations and it
would it would start participating in
the conversation well if you know the
story that bot went went bad very very
quickly and it started spewing out some
really really bad things on social media
so that's an example of it wasn't
necessarily the software that was
designed poorly it was but it was
designed correctly but it was misused
okay so there are situations where you
can totally design your software
completely correctly and people will
find a way to misuse it we do have that
problem in autonomous vehicles as well
all right so if you've ever worked in uh
safety engineering or systems
engineering we and the Legacy systems
engineering community use the what we
call the V model okay for safety
engineering and systems engineering on
the left hand side of the V you'd you
define your system you define high level
requirements for your system you
architect your system you you allocate
requirements to different units of your
system and on the right hand side of the
V you do your validation and
verification you test all the possible
things you try to test the requirements
of your system you try to expose your
system to all the possible things that
you think can go wrong when the when the
software is being used in the field and
at the end of the day you generate a
safety case that says
here's our here's the design of our
system here's the requirements that we
impose safety and system requirements we
impose in our system here's the tests we
did in our system and here's a list of
evidence and arguments that say our
system is is safe to and and is absent
of unreasonable risk no system is ever
going to be completely absent of risk
but you have to make a case that it's
absent of unreasonable risk okay
so again when we start introducing AI
components learning components
what does it mean to write a requirement
for an AI component okay you can't say
okay for all possible inputs of this
neural network the output has to be
always be bounded to this range it's
just it it's impossible to do it's it's
may not be impossible but it's very very
difficult to do okay and again there's
standards committees right now that are
trying to figure this out what does it
mean to write a requirement safety
requirement for an AI component we don't
know I'm on I'm on a committee right now
that's trying to do this and I just had
a call with with one of my colleagues in
the UK this morning we're trying to
answer that question we don't know it's
a it's a work in progress okay
when you have conventional software and
when I talk about conventional software
I'm talking about python C C plus plus
that sort of thing where you can
actually see the inside of the software
and you can debug it you know okay I've
got this little unit that does this I
got this little unit that does this
um you develop an architecture
um and you develop an architecture so
that you can Define little units and
what what little each little unit each
little function is supposed to do so
when you go to test it and something
goes wrong you can point to the internal
function that went wrong how do you do
that with a neural network okay I don't
know you can you know you have nodes you
have layers you have you know
convolutional you have lstn you have all
the different kinds of neural networks
but the innards are mysterious with what
you call unexplainable okay
very very different from conventional
software
how do we verify an AI component okay
how do we know that we've exposed it to
all possible input states that a neural
network a perception Network for example
a neural network that's responsible for
observing objects in the driving
environment and making classifications
about pedestrian bicycle automobile tree
dog uh person in a wheelchair a person
on a scooter you know
how do we verify that we've captured all
the possible things that could go wrong
with that AI component very very
difficult to do and then finally how do
we know when we've covered the entire
set of possible things that this AI
component could be exposed to and how
can we reasonably say how can we
um
say with any level of confidence that
we've exposed this AI component this
learning component to uh enough possible
uh input states that we can say that the
the we've reduced the unreasonable risk
to a manageable level extremely
difficult to do
okay
oh by the way I didn't mention that ISO
26262 is one of the standards that's
that guides the development of
Automotive software
um so it's been used for decades to
guide the development of software that
has safety implications like your cruise
control software in your vehicle for
example uh it's used for example on Adas
autonomous driving assistant systems
like the Tesla vehicle okay and it's
really just follows the V model and it
tells you to do all of these things and
the reason I have a crossout is because
when you try to answer these questions
like like I've been posing here about
how you write a requirement how do you
ever how do you adequately verify an AI
component frankly ISO 262 is an epic
fail okay in that regard and that's why
that you know where they form these
subcommittees to try to address those
there's another standard called ISO
21448 that came came out very recently
um called Safety of the intended
functionality okay and I borrowed this
from a from a presentation that I
thought was really really good about
safety of the intended functionality so
if I got that from the internet it was
an ansys so diff in 60 minutes
uh there it is okay
um
and the idea is
o 262 which we call functional safety
deals with develop your software so that
it it's absent of bugs develop your
Hardware so that your Hardware that's
hosting your software doesn't cause any
failures so you can imagine that if you
have an autonomous vehicle and your
Hardware is free of failure uh your
software is free of bugs there are still
things that can go wrong okay for
example there's a few examples that are
given here
um the sun is shining directly into your
camera okay uh Somebody went and pasted
something on a stop sign okay somebody
in a you know misused something and then
put a you know I don't know what that
picture is putting a can of uh uh energy
drink or something on the wheel I don't
know what that means but there's all
kinds of things that can go wrong that
can cause your autonomous system even
though it was developed you know with
the with utmost of care it's still going
to fail in the field because of what we
call these sodiff issues okay yeah
so with that I'm gonna by the way I
should have mentioned at the beginning
feel free to I'm going to leave some
time at the end for questions and
answers but if you have a question that
pops up I'm happy to you know entertain
any questions that pop up during the
they're going to talk okay so these are
well-known known challenges with AI
safety uh but they are particularly uh
acute problems when you're talking about
uh AI when used in an autonomy in the
context of an autonomous vehicle uh AI
is brittle okay
and what I mean by that is you know you
train your AI
um you set all the weights you test it
and everything as long as the
um the neural network is being exposed
to inputs that are well within the
distribution the training distribution
it'll probably perform pretty well but
as soon as you get close to that
boundary or outside of the distribution
the the output can be nonsensical and I
used a nonsense nonsensical example just
to to to to illustrate the point here
you know cat if I give it a you know 100
different pictures of a cat you know in
an easy to recognize pose
no problem classifying it as a cat but
as soon as I introduce it to some you
know small variation to that like the
cat licking its paw the neural network
was the things that it's a cat you know
eating a lot of ice cream cone it's
nonsensical okay the other challenge is
AI is opaque okay again you may have a
very well behaved Network and it's very
very well behaved you give it inputs it
produces an output it correctly
classifies the output but if it does
something slightly wrong or something
majorly wrong how do you go in like with
conventional software you can go into
your C plus plus your python code and
debug the software how do you do that
with a neural network uh it's an open
question and again there are techniques
that are being developed to be able to
make AI explainable but you know for the
purposes that we need to be able to to
to
debug code you know according to safety
engineering practices it's not quite
there yet
um intractable State space okay so I
talked a little bit about this in
conventional software uh we like to be
able to understand the entire space
input space that could be an input to
our software component during its uh
useful lifetime okay
um and we all like to be able to
characterize what the output is going to
do given that entire space of input when
you're talking about neural network
especially when you're talking about
something like a perception algorithm on
the Thomas vehicle and all just imagine
all the crazy kinds of things that you
know a branch is hanging over a traffic
light traffic light is moving in the
wind a person wearing a costume on
Halloween is entering the road you know
somebody in a bear costume just
the the the input space for a neural
network convolutional neural network
perception algorithm just it's
intractable okay and therefore there
it's extremely difficult to be able to
characterize the output space okay
and then lastly
um the outputs of a neural network are
probabilistic they're not going to tell
you I I'm going to tell you with 100
certainty that this is a cat or this is
a dog or this is a banana or this is a
pedestrian nope it's going to say I have
X amount of confidence X percent
confidence that this is a pedestrian uh
that this is an automobile this is a
bicyclist this is a a scooter entering
the road okay
in an autonomous vehicle we have to make
safety critical decisions based on
probabilistic information so if you've
ever taken a course with Michael
kochendurfer this is the classic example
of uh decision making in the presence of
uncertainty
okay so again there's a whole panoply of
challenges with AI safety these are ones
that I believe are very very specific
and acute for the autonomous driving
space
okay and I think we talked a little bit
about this already
um you know again AI is brittle how do
you write a requirement that says for
all possible inputs to the neural
network uh it can never give me a wrong
classification or it can give me a it
gives give me a wrong classification
only you know 10 of the time five
percent of time very very difficult to
do AI is opaque
um how do you define an architecture how
do you define a neural network in such a
way that you can test the individual
components very difficult to do
we talked about how do you verify
um
you know in your in your validation and
verification you want to expose your
neural network or your safety critical
Software System to all the possible
things that you think they could be
exposed to in the wild you know when
it's actually in operation and we do
this with a combination of simulation so
we can run millions of simulations uh
and expose our our software uh to all
kinds of scenarios and simulation we can
do closed course testing where we
actually drive the vehicle with the
software around on a closed course where
we have control over what you know what
the vehicle can be exposed to and then
finally we have what we call Public Road
evaluation where we have very very
controlled conditions like a Chase car
you know one a human-driven vehicle
behind and in front of the autonomous
vehicle when we're testing it so it can
drive out on the road and gather data
and you can test so there's a there's a
number of ways that you can do it but
actually being able to confidently say
that you've exposed your software to the
entire
uh Universe of things that it may
experience in the wild is very very
difficult to do so I'm going to talk
um in a second about some of the
research topics that I think are um are
very promising for addressing some of
these issues and uh but let me let me
first talk about a typical autonomous
vehicle software so autonomous vehicles
operate on the sense plan act uh
methodology so you have the sense uh
block where you have a number of sensors
that your vehicle is driving around it's
got cameras it's got lidars It's got
Radars it's got you know sometimes
sonars and and these are intended to be
able to
um sense everything in the environment
okay the autonomous vehicle needs to
know uh where the pedestrians where the
crosswalks where the traffic lights
where are the intersections uh where the
curbs is that a building over there is
there an intersection here is there a
left turn all kinds of things and the
sensors help do that we use a
multi multimodal sensors meaning you
know cameras lidars and Radars because
each of those uh has has uh benefits and
drawbacks uh in in an environment so if
cameras for example are very very good
at doing uh classification of objects
but they they're not very good at night
they're not very good when you're facing
into the sun uh that sort of thing
Radars are very very good at detecting
range and velocity of other vehicles but
if you're driving near iron structures
near Iron Bridge or something there's a
lot of iron bridges in Pittsburgh you
get a lot of spurious Reflections from
your radar similar with lidar there's
some things that lidar's really really
good at uh and some things that it's not
good at so you put take all these
sensors you put all of them on your
vehicle when I showed that picture of
the um
of motionless vehicle you can see a
whole bunch of and I'm sure you see like
their Cruise Cruise Vehicles drive
around here a lot I know and you see
those you see those things uh on it all
the time okay so that's the sensors the
semantic map is where you have a like a
Google Maps version of the the space
that the vehicle is going to be driving
in but you know I mean and there are
some instances where the vehicle can
learn on its own what the features are
in a map okay but it's more typical that
you'll have a Google map representation
of the streets uh and the you know the
urban environment that the vehicle is
going to drive through and a human has
to take those Google Maps and manually
annotate this is a tree this is a curve
this is the this is the lane divider
this is the intersection
um this is a stop sign okay and yes
why are there two semantic Maps yeah
good question it's actually the same
semantic map that's used in in both
instances okay there's not two separate
semantic Maps there's and I it's just I
didn't want to draw a line going from
one semantic map over to the other so
one semantic map it's used in in
multiple locations okay
paint and these steps like incense it's
a semantic map that's in like this state
and in a plan it changes or is it is
that when the update takes place yeah so
so okay so
the semantic map itself doesn't change
but the part of the map that you're
interested in is going to be different
okay because I'm I have a I may have a
semantic map for the entire uh space
that I'm going to be driving through in
Las Vegas let's say and there are
selected routes and streets uh that are
mapped out okay but if I'm driving near
the Luxor casino let's say I only care
about the map features that are within
say 100 meters of where I am now okay so
the vehicle has to know which portion of
the map to uh to invoke to pull at any
point in time okay and it uses the uses
the um the localization function to be
able to know the vehicle has to know
where it is to know which portion of the
map it's driving in Okay so
if the localization is wrong okay if
there's error in your localization
you're gonna make a mistake about which
portion of the map that you pull in okay
yes
what do you ground truth on
uh again we so we ground you can talk
about in the in the generation of the
semantic map uh no so in terms of
localization of the car like you guys
use plan or is it it's a it's a vert so
I can't get into like the super
technical details but it's a it's it's
very similar to slam yes yep
okay good questions all right okay so
the in the sense block again we've got
sensors we've got a semantic map that
tells us where we are and what the
features are in the area that we're
driving in and then again this ego
localization where again we have to do
some some version of Slam okay
um using sensor information
at the you know
um uh immediate sensor information to
tell us where we are in the map okay uh
all of that gets fed into a uh a neural
network that has to generate a list of
tracked objects okay so the the
perception prediction neural network has
to say
okay that's a pedestrian over there and
that pedestrian is you know 10 meters
away from me and moving you know at this
speed in this Direction that's a vehicle
on the heading of that other vehicle is
you know this many degrees with respect
to some reference and all of these
things have to be uh uh produced in real
time okay on you know iterations of tens
or hundreds of milliseconds every time
you know at every instance uh all of
these things and again just imagine the
types of things that can go wrong with
that okay uh you're never going to have
perfect knowledge of the of the scene
you're never going to have perfect
localization you're never going to have
perfect estimates of positions
velocities headings uh of the other
agents in the scene okay you also have
to predict where these agents are going
to be in the future okay most uh product
perception prediction systems in
autonomous vehicles tell you make
estimates of where those things are
right now but they also make estimates
about where they're going to be a few
seconds from now okay
and that's that's that's not easy to do
so what the sense ultimately the sense
block produces this list of tracked
objects in the scene and then again we
use the same semantic map but we use a
section of the semantic map that's
relevant to where the vehicle is right
now
um and the eagle localization to say
okay I'm right here
this is the map that I'm in this is the
this is the um uh environment that I'm
driving in and this is the list of
static and dynamic objects in the scene
so now I have to create an optimal
trajectory I have to plan an optimal
path for the ego vehicle uh to drive
through and again you have to optimize
for obviously first and foremost you
have to optimize for not colliding with
other we call them vrus vulnerable Road
users pedestrians bicyclists uh
automobiles okay you don't want to
collide with the static infrastructure
either you don't want to hit a telephone
pole you don't want to hit a stop sign
uh you don't want to cross the
um you don't want to cross the um the
stop line for an intersection okay
you want to make sure that you maintain
sufficient clearance from other from
other actors in the scene there's also
more subtle things that you have to do
like following the rules of the road
okay maintaining the the proper speed
limit okay this is where the annotated
map comes in okay the annotated map is
going to tell you the speed limit in
this section of road is 35 miles per
there's a speed bump over there so
reduce your velocity any of those things
you get wrong the vehicle is not going
to be able to react to them because it's
not going to know okay
um
so again with this imperfect information
that's fed to the motion planner the
motion planner has to make its best
guess on the safest path for the vehicle
to follow and then that so that's the
plan part and then the ACT part is it
provides a trajectory to the actual
vehicle and uh that gets turned into
control commands throttle brake
um and uh steering okay those are the
three control actions that a vehicle to
throttle break and steering okay
so when we talked about the challenge of
AI being brittle okay
as long as the stop sign and The
Pedestrian uh is in you know perfectly
visible and I could see the whole
pedestrian they're not occluded by some
other pedestrian they're not included by
a bush they're not included by a stop
sign or a mailbox no problem I'll do a
pretty good job of classifying and
predicting their future State
um and this is where sodiff comes in
safety of the antenna functionality
there's all kinds of things
environmental factors curvature of the
road that can cause your sensors to
imperfectly and not Faithfully represent
the ground truth of the scene that
you're in okay
the motion planner has no concept of
that the motion planner says just says
the information I'm getting for
perception that's that's the best
information that I have okay
so again this this problem of uh inputs
to the neural network that are out of
distribution uh or near the distribution
boundary that could cause you to
misclassify
misclassify an object uh tend to you
know turn out being severe
and you might say well you know if I
misclassify a pedestrian as a mailbox
let's say
um
you know pedestrians standing on the on
the on the sidewalk if I misclassified
as a mailbox I'm still okay because the
vehicle is not gonna it's gonna try to
avoid hitting the mailbox okay and
that's true but remember we're making
predictions about where these things are
going to be in the future so if I
classify something as a mailbox I'm
going to assume that it's going to stay
there okay if it's really a pedestrian
then it has the possibility at any
moment of stepping into the road and uh
you know causing you know I can I can
collide with it so the brittleness of AI
is is particularly
um Troublesome there AIO is opaque so
let's say again we're testing out our
perception algorithm we're feeding at
all these inputs uh we feed it an input
and it gives us the wrong answer okay
conventional software you can go in you
can debug your python you can debug your
C pretty quickly much more difficult to
do when we're talking about a neural
network
um
this is one I I was just talking about
the motion planner is getting
imperfect
uh information from it could get
imperfect wrong information from the
semantic map it could get not could it
will it will get wrong information from
the localization system it will get
wrong information from the perception
prediction system okay and yet it still
has to make safety a critical decision
it cannot it cannot cause a collision
okay
so given those challenges I'm going to
talk just briefly about some of the
research topics in AI safety that I
think are more promising uh the most
promising ones to deal with these okay
uh the first one is this notion of
um
uncertainty aware AI okay and there's a
you know I just put up some some papers
on you know calibrational neural
networks and uncertain there's a lot
more in fact I think Michael
cochendurfer's one of Michael
cookendurfer student published a paper a
a year or two ago around uh being able
to detect when when an input is out of
distribution
um and I believe that this uh area of
research is going to mature more quickly
than making neural networks more robust
to to uh you know more robust and less
brittle and the idea here is
if I get an input to my neural network
um that's going to cause me to make a
wrong classification if I can be made
aware of that okay I can do something
about it if you think about yourself as
a driver okay if you're coming on there
you have uncertainty all the time uh
when you're making decisions when you're
driving okay you're you're driving down
the road and there's a bunch of parked
cars along the side you're aware that
you know some kid May uh come you know
run out or a bicycle or scooter they run
out you don't see it it's not in your
current view field of view but you know
that it could happen okay
so in the same way if a neural network
could
um actually detect and give us
notification
that there may we may have difficulty
correctly classifying an input we can we
can account for that in the motion
planner we might uh slow down we might
uh you know be more cautious as we
proceed down the road as instead of how
we would otherwise do it so again I
think this notion of uncertainty aware
AI uh confidence uh it has to be
reliable though it has to be reliable
you can't just take the output like of a
softmax layer uh and trust that that
soft Max of confidence scores are are
notoriously unreliable
um
that this idea of AI being opaque and I
talked earlier about
um you know validation and verification
where we have to expose our agent to as
many a possible scenes as as we can
um
and try to you know assess the behavior
of it
um
again and if something goes wrong we'd
like to dig in and understand into our
code what went wrong again because AI is
opaque it's very difficult to do so
Michael cochinder for Anthony Corso
Robert Moss a couple of years ago
introduced me to this uh concept of
adaptive stress testing and black box
methods in general for assessing
um uh safety critical aspects of of
neural network code and it and we've
applied it I know Stanford has applied
it to an autonomous vehicle issues to
show that in a second uh when I was at
GE we applied the Adaptive stress
testing method to find uh difficult to
find yet still probable failures in a
trajectory uh planner for a for for an
aircraft okay so I again this whole
notion of developing Black Box methods
that are adaptive so that they can more
rapidly get to a failure State than say
a typical
um uh random
uh Monte Carlo random Monte Carlo
sampling I think AST is very promising
in that regard in being able to rapidly
discover
failures in in a black box system this
is I I bought and I told Anthony I was
going to use this
um so I don't get in trouble this is an
example of adaptive stress testing that
was applied to an autonomous vehicle
using an intelligent open source
intelligent driver model in that vehicle
and um
the system under test was the
intelligent driver model and they had to
developed an adversarial agent based on
reinforcement learning
that would adaptively perturb some
stochastic environmental variables and
would find the most likely sequence of
sampled variables that would lead to a
collision in this particular video the
um in this particular research work the
um the acceleration the velocity and the
acceleration I don't know if it's
position velocity or acceleration of The
Pedestrian were perturbed and the noise
on the sensor for the perception
algorithm was perturbed and they found
this for this you know conspiracy of
values of these stochastic variables
that cause the intelligent driver model
to believe that it had a conflict-free
path when in fact there was a pedestrian
there and it struck The Pedestrian so we
are currently working on uh
incorporating adaptive stress testing to
test our motion planner at motional
Harrison de lucky here one of your
colleagues is uh is is helping us to do
that Anthony Corso are working on trying
to adapt this adaptive stress testing
approach to try to find
failures in our in our
in our uh motion planner motionless
motion planner and lastly decision
making under uncertainty
um let me first talk about uncertainty
if you're familiar with the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse uh I like to
think of these as like the Four Horsemen
of the Apocalypse for uncertainty for
autonomous systems so first you have
multimodal uncertainty okay
uncertainty around the future behaviors
of other actors in the scene okay you
may be driving along as a pedestrian
walking along the side of road you have
no idea if that pedestrian is going to
turn and start jaywalking into the road
okay
um if you're driving on the Eco vehicle
is driving along there in the blue
there's another vehicle driving on the
right
um we you know we have to make
predictions about what that agent
vehicle and all the objects in the scene
we have to make predictions about what
those are going to do okay so the orange
agent vehicle it could keep going
straight uh it could you know cut into
our lane you know quite a bit ahead of
us and then make a left turn or it could
abruptly cut in okay we just don't know
what's going to do you know several
seconds out so we have to make
predictions about those types of things
uh existence uncertainty is the second
of the Four Horsemen of uncertainty
um and this is
there are all kinds of things that can
cause what we call false positives
they're they're a little thing a a ghost
vehicle can pop into the scene okay
um and a ghost vehicle your perception
algorithm thinks that there's something
there and it's going to be telling the
motion planner hey you better react to
that you better break start breaking
because there's something there well it
turns out it turns out that it's a ghost
vehicle and you break you have
unintended braking which can cause other
safety uh issues like you somebody can
run into you from behind okay
the the next one is track uncertainty
track uncertainty means that um
I think I I touched on this earlier
I'm making I'm making
estimates of positions velocities and
headings okay of all of the objects in
the scene okay
um those those all will have error
associated with them okay I'm going to
have error in the position estimated
position of the other agents and seeing
errors in their velocities errors in
their headings okay and then the last
one
is classification uncertainty which I
think we've talked about a lot and I
mentioned earlier that um we we drive
motionless vehicles on the Las Vegas
Strip uh and I've had the privilege of
writing in in the vehicle twice in the
back of the uh motionless vehicle in Las
Vegas strip you want to talk about crazy
nobody followed them no pedestrians
follow the rules there they don't care
if the lights red or green they're just
going to cross the road uh people are
walking around with crazy costumes
they're doing crazy things uh people you
know people are drunk and they're
walking around like brownie in motion
it's nuts okay
it's nuts okay the fact that our our
vehicles can safely navigate through
through scenes like that is nothing
short of amazing to me
Okay so
one of the reasons why we care so much
about this uncertainty is
when we generate a trajectory for our
motion planner
for the vehicle to follow
uh we want to do a collision cost okay
we want to say
do we predict that our ego's trajectory
is going to intersect with any of those
predicted trajectories of those of those
um vehicles of those other vehicles
pedestrians in the scene okay and
there's a lot of research done that says
that uh you know there's curves that say
if you strike a pedestrian at uh I can't
read what the numbers are but at 10
miles an hour you're not gonna you're
not gonna uh you know five ten miles an
hour you're not likely to cause severe
injury I mean you know I might you know
give them a bruise or something once you
start getting like
30 40 miles per hour as you get higher
and higher speed the likelihood of
causing severe injury or death goes up
dramatically okay
um and so when you think about
predicting positions velocities and
headings of these future
um
uh uh of these future predictions for
these agents in the scene pedestrians
and Automobiles and bicyclists we have
to make a uh a prediction about if we
were to strike them what would be the
kinetic energy transfer okay that's one
that's a common method that people are
using now to uh it's not just Collision
but if there is a collision what is the
expected kinetic energy transfer between
the vehicle and that other object okay
and as as you can imagine that kinetic
energy calculation uh is going to be
dramatically affected by these
uncertainties okay by the position The
Heading and the velocity of those other
actors in the scene okay so this is one
way that these errors can manifest
themselves in you can incorrectly uh uh
under calculate the amount of kinetic
energy that you would transfer you can
and you know so which which would be an
unsafe situation you can incorrectly
over calculate
um uh how much kinetic energy you may
think that you're going to transfer a
lot of energy when in fact you're you're
not even gonna you're gonna graze that
object or you're not even going to touch
it which would may cause you to to break
unnecessarily okay
all right so this is a this is a project
that's near and dear to Essence heart
and and Ellie and Alex who are
contributing to this I couldn't get the
version that had Ellie and Alex's names
on there but this idea of uh
reachability analysis reachable state so
we just and we just started this like
early this year uh an Essen and team
have made a lot of progress on this the
this notion of
calculating the reachable states for
agents in the scene okay and snn team
are are putting together a simulation in
Carlo currently where they're trying to
predict the reachable states of agents
in a scene and then if you have an ego
trajectory can you if the ego trajectory
uh intersects at all with any of those
reachable States then you can assume
that there's a collision and we're going
she's going to and she and the team are
going to expand that to include uh
uncertainties around right now you're
only including including position
uncertainty you're starting to add
acceleration uncertainty steering
uncertainty but we've got to get a
heading uncertain anyway I think this is
a promising approach as Essen will tell
you there's a lot of work there's a lot
of research being done out there on
reachability analysis applied to this
type of problem one of the big
challenges is though making it
um computationally efficient because
remember you have limited compute
resources on these vehicles and these
algorithms have to run iterate in 10
minutes seconds 50 milliseconds 100
milliseconds you need to have techniques
techniques may work very well in
simulation but when you actually try to
run them on a Target uh Hardware with
limited resources uh and limited time to
iterate uh computational efficiency
becomes very important
um there's another project that I'm
doing with a small company called
critical systems Labs out of Vancouver
they're supporting us and they're doing
something that's quite similar to what
Essen is doing but it's a but but
we're not really using the you know
formal reachability analysis we're
saying
um so those those expand those those
sort of fans that are Fanning out are
what are the where are the possible
locations that these agents can be at
Future steps in time based on where they
are where we detecting them to be now
and this idea of Maximum Control
Authority okay so if we did if we if we
um classify something as a bicycle uh we
know that it's not going to be able to
go 50 miles an hour okay if we classify
something as a pedestrian we know that
uh you know it's not going to be a
high-speed Runner not every individual
is going to be you know an Olympic an
Olympic Athlete so we can put limits on
um you know what we call their maximum
Control Authority and this notion of you
know what are the possible future states
that these things can be that these
agents can be in and then we can do a
sort of a probabilistic calculation of
of Collision in a kinetic energy
transfer
um
the reachability analysis and the
maximum Control Authority and heat Maps
notion are things that you can do after
a trajectory has been generated by your
motion planner so your motion planner
generates a trajectory you can use these
techniques to test whether your
trajectory will actually be in a you
know future collision with any of these
agents
um
but they don't deal with the generation
of the trajectory in the first place
okay
some work that that is generally called
stochastic MPC model predictive control
is really looking at how do you
incorporate these uncertainties into the
optimization process where you're
generating your trajectory in the first
place okay and if you're familiar with
model predictive controls you have a you
have a model of your system and you're
trying to
generate an optimal control action that
will result in the next future State the
optimal next future State okay uh and
stochastic NPC is is saying okay
if I now have multiple possible future
states of these other actors in the
scene both in position velocity and
heading how do we how do I incorporate
that into my optimization okay and it
really has to do with how you how you
establish the constraints for your for
your uh Optimizer for your solver okay
in in traditional MPC uh the constraints
are you just have inequality constraints
so this variable has to you know has to
be less than the Delta uh in order to
come up with an optimal solution one of
the things that stochastic MPC looks at
is instead of having just a straight
inequality constraint you look at what
is the probability that these
constraints will
um will um you know will be below a
certain a certain threshold over over
some time step one of the other things
that they do uh and I've got sort of
links to these and this is going to be
recorded and made available to everyone
so
um
if I've got
one possible
predicted path for an agent in my scene
and that is he's driving along me the
vehicle's driving alongside me it's most
likely it is going to keep on going but
it could abruptly cut in front of me
okay one of the things that one of these
papers does is it says okay can I sort
of blend those future States together
and so that I'm not bouncing around with
my control algorithms you know on this
iteration I'm assuming that it's going
straight so I set up control action for
myself to deal with that but if it cuts
in front of me then you know I haven't I
haven't planned for the optimal control
action but if I consider both the
nominal and the worst case and I sort of
blend those States together then I can
come up with a optimal control action
that uh that that that is uh resilient
to to all future possibilities and the
one on the left is if I constrain my
control action to account for nominal
versus worst case so a lot of good
research being done there and there's a
bunch of other stuff there's probability
probabilistic safety envelopes chance
constrained optimization which I talked
about a bit there is uh more and more
research being done on taking a Tom DP
approach if you've ever worked with or
taken a class from Michael cookendurfer
you know that he's uh he really likes on
omdps in the world expert at Palm DP so
all really interesting stuff so
um
I do want to just sort of briefly talk
about I want to make sure I leave Quest
time for more q a at the end
um
so again this is another open question
around how you quantify risk uh in
autonomous vehicles and and
um Robert has been doing through the
center for AI safety has been doing some
really interesting work with Allstate
that I became aware of late last year
and I've been continuing to sort of
investigate this because I think there's
there's something there
um but in the in in the autonomous
vehicle space when we talk about risk
there's this notion of positive risk
balance okay and if if you're familiar
with the Hippocratic Oath it's a first
Do no harm okay so in order to gain the
trust of the public as we introduce
these autonomous systems into in you
know onto public roads we want to make
sure that we have what's called a
positive risk balance which means that
if it had been a human driver or when
you put an autonomous vehicle on the
road
it doesn't increase the amount of risk
that you would have had
if it were a human driver okay and the
AV autonomous vehicle Community likes to
tout the fact that uh autonomous
vehicles Don't Drive Drunk they don't
text while driving okay they don't they
don't uh uh they're not distracted when
they're driving unless they have bad
inputs of course
um
a a a about two-thirds of all accidents
in the U.S are caused by distracted
driving impaired driving and
um I think the third one was the
violations of the rules of the road okay
so I think you know the autonomous
vehicles have the promise of of having
what we call a positive risk balance
okay but but these committees that are
coming up with these Notions of of risk
they haven't really given us any sort of
metrics or methodologies to quantify uh
how much risk there is okay so and uh
Robert will will be very familiar with
this uh uh took these I took these from
a report from Allstate so
from an insurance from an insurance
perspective when an insurer cares about
whether they're insuring a human-driven
vehicle autonomous vehicle or a person's
life they care about severity uh versus
frequency okay
how frequent is a loss uh expected to
happen and how frequent is is expected
to happen when we're talking about
autonomous vehicles uh it's very very
hard to generate the entire distribution
because there's some Rand study that
said he had to drive like a billion
miles uh to get a statistically
significant estimate of you know how
many collisions an autonomous vehicle
would have throughout its lifetime okay
um
let me talk about this this histogram so
what the All-State work with Robert has
done is that is it's
um in simulation they've run a several
intelligent driver models in simulation
and uh exposed them to all different
kinds of snares and I think they used
adaptive stress testing as well to
generate that but they Bend uh the
severities of collisions uh according to
um closing rate right closing rate and
the closing rate is a function of if I
do collide with something How likely is
it to cause minor injury uh moderate
injury severe injury death okay and they
they normalized this this sort of
severity scale and they came up with
sort of a histogram of uh the likelihood
of frequency of of of of different types
of events and then what I thought was
really Innovative and interesting is
that they borrowed some techniques and
methodologies from the financial
industry where the financial industry
when you you know you're you're managing
a stock portfolio a future performance
of a stock portfolio or anything
Financial
any Financial product is
non-deterministic it's probabilistic but
financial institutions need to be able
to plan for you know worst case events
and so they developed this metric called
value at risk which says if I establish
how much risk I'm willing to
um to incur okay what is the probability
that in the over the next say month year
trading cycle what's the probability
that I'm actually going to incur a a a a
loss event in the financial loss event
at that level or higher okay
and they again I thought this was very
Innovative applied that metric to this
uh distribution of frequency versus the
library of collisions for an autonomous
vehicle we we don't have this whole
distribution for autonomous nobody has
this whole distribution for an
autonomous vehicle because you just have
to drive too many miles to generate it
especially the the long tail okay but if
we can generate part of the distribution
okay uh we could actually estimate in
fact really one of my colleagues
emotional uh wrote a paper that says if
you have like the the left part of the
distribution you can infer that a log
normal distribution and make and make uh
estimates based on that but but with
this metric if we had this distribution
we could now say you know if if we
um say that we're not willing to an
atonement in our av operation we're not
willing to tolerate a uh collision with
a severity above say severe injury we
could actually use this methodology to
calculate the probability
um that will actually incur an event
like that and it's a it's a nice metric
so
um just real quick because I'm running
out of time here the standards committee
all
um I don't know if I shared this with
you yet Robert I think I might have
um
standards committees are trying to think
about this too and there was a recent
paper that came out from some
researchers in Sweden that are
developing this quantitative risk Norm
okay because positive risk balance
really just says hey I don't want to
cause a collision or I don't want to
cause more collisions than a human
driver would cause but
the the standard there's one sort of
research researchers from Sweden which
are on are helping to develop standards
are saying well we need to bucket these
uh uh Collision events into levels of
severity okay and develop this
quantitative risk Norm that says Okay
um
can we have a metric that says we're not
likely to have a a a collision above
some above some uh severity and I think
it it it dovetails very nicely it's
totally independent from the work you
did with Allstate but I think it
dovetails very nicely if you could
actually attach the VAR calculation to
this notion of a quantitative risk Norm
okay uh last topic
um and this is the one that I was
talking about and this is from my
colleague Paul Schmidt who works out of
the Boston office promotional he's been
doing this work for about a year and
this has to do with perceived safety not
objective safety but perceived safety
and it's it's it's expressive robotics
project okay so imagine you're walking
down the street you're a pedestrian
you're walking in traffic okay and
you're getting ready to cross the road
um and there's Vehicles you know in the
road coming towards you what sort of
cues are you looking for as a human what
sort of things are you looking for to
um give yourself assurance that the
vehicle is going to stop okay prior to
you coming out on the road okay and that
was really the basis for for this uh
study and what they did was they built a
virtual environment uh and there's one
of my colleagues Kim Ryan with with VR
glasses there and they had some um you
know they picked some random
participants emotional employee
participants to walk around this virtual
environment with autonomous vehicles
driving around and they experimented
what sorts of gestures could the AV uh
Express to give the person in the
virtual world confidence and actually
step out onto the virtually step out
into the road and you may have seen you
may see Vehicles driving around Thomas
vehicle with these lights uh that are ex
that are that are intended to sort of
give you a visual cue
um of what the vehicle is intending to
do but it turns out that the flashing
lights didn't work so well so what was
what this team
um
as we experimented with are things like
expressive deceleration where the
vehicle would actually when it sensed
that there was a pedestrian on the side
of the road it would it would
expressively decelerate in other words
it would let you know that was
decelerating okay by you know making
like break sounds or tipping the nose
forward uh stopping short of where it
would normally stop if there were not a
pedestrian there and they ran a bunch of
these studies with uh with human
participants so this is an example of
you know break sounds
um you know reducing the RPM you know
winding down the engine and some some of
these were actually fake fake sounds but
if the vehicle could be you know trained
on what sorts of cues it could give to
the to The Pedestrian public that would
give them more confidence
um so anyway they did this this work is
published and is being presented at icra
in May
um and they've and they found some
interesting results around you know some
some like the vehicle stopping short
ahead of where it would normally stop
turned out to be a cue that gave
the virtual I mean the pedestrians in
the virtual environment confidence that
they could step into the road
um and then stopping stopping short
Behavior I said I was going to leave
time for questions and I took up all the
time uh thank you that's the end of my
talk but
um I did want to leave it sorry Elon
hopefully this talk has convinced you
that the time is driving self-driving
cars is categorically not solved no way
not even close
I hope we have time I hope we have time
for Quest thank you very much
okay
how you um are sure that the simulation
environment is Representatives
that is an unbelievably good question we
don't the short answer is that we don't
uh and we're actually currently
conducting correlation so the question
was hey we can run all these scenarios
in simulation with our autonomous
vehicle uh but how do we know that that
that set of conditions and scenarios are
truly representative of what the vehicle
is going to um experience in the real
world it's a great question and we're
currently conducting correlation study
where we're running situations in
situations in simulation and when
comparing those to the types of
situations that our actual vehicles are
being exposed to on the road and trying
to trying to correlate those two and
trying to get the simulation to be more
representative and there's a whole field
of study uh around that as well
so do we have time for any other
questions
oh yeah people have to leave I I'm sorry
I took up all the time but uh thank you
very much
yeah say people can I'm happy to stick
around yeah if people want to stick
around and ask more questions but thank
you very much
[Applause]